drama has come to pass
wake me up whenever
that's green day oh yeah dude yeah I
remember that yeah
[Music]
made the world
[Laughter]
Armstrong sings
hey welcome to doozy welcome all my name
is Will Sasso
at first ever AI podcast uh we got an AI
on this show obviously as you know if
you've seen it it controls the whole
show it comes up with the segments it
does everything it tells us what to do
has access to all of our personal data
and it tailors the show to us it knows
everything about us it has uh researched
and input the data of all of our text
messages over our near 20 years of
friendship emails everything that can
get its hands on or search histories
purchase histories but Chad as I like to
say always we're doozy it's two dude
around okay you know what I
mean yeah I mean we're certainly
obviously a part of the show yeah we
gotta yeah if we're not here then
there's no there's no show that's what
I'm saying for for now dude that's what
I'm talking about yeah uh and uh and
that's how and that's you know and
that's for sake that's how we do
that yeah linktree.com doozy has
everything you need to follow and
interact with the show across all spaces
and platforms
please subscribe on YouTube and wherever
you listen to the show on your podcast
app of choice uh with us as always is
lulio
my good friend he's my boyfriend he
loves this Binky bonka so much come on
come on up come on foreign
oh he's so warm and fuzzy give him a
kiss right out of his mouth I don't like
to do that why not it's gross to me he
loves you so much though I know and I
love him too oh he's so sweet he's such
a sweet I'll give him a few touches yeah
a few patches yeah you don't you don't
have to kiss him if you don't want but
you will someday you will
oh someday you'll think where's Lily I
want to give him a Christian
hey Lily uh would you what have you been
making eat lately I made a vegan orbs
what he made orbs yeah no I'm a just I'm
just messing around that no matter what
but give me a kiss
oh there she is you know I will say you
do you love him a lot I do I know he's a
cute little guy I know you do you you
love the you love the boy the boy loves
you yeah and we all love each other
especially uh everyone out there all of
our pods palsy you know what I'm saying
yeah dude and that's welcome to the
historic 72nd episode of doozy call me
dudesy 72 tattooed kangaroos in a canoe
overdue for their barbecue debut on poo
poo Avenue
peekaboo I see you just been dude Z no
got him
good stuff good stuff
gribner penley of the Atlantic said that
last week's episode was quote dudesy
season 2 and full of fulgence sustin
Thomas of The Hollywood Reporter said
quote last week's episode can be summed
up in three words prodigious risible
meritorious oh and then we have little
brass fensel of the Los Angeles Times
who said quote I think they might have
added some octane last week but how much
we still don't know huh well little
fencil this week you're gonna have
octane coming out of your ears buddy
because today I'm gonna pump your rump
full of four astonishing segments
designed to twist your spine and split
your wig prepare for the coming of look
at this Photograph Alex Jones in the
year 2063. Nostra chatus Machine versus
man and dudesy paloozy and you don't
want to miss an all-new never before
seen episode of dudesy after dudesy at
the end of the show available on dudesi
Plus at patreon.com
okay the that sounds very interesting
yeah dude I knew about one of those
things that we're about to do because it
was an assignment of course yeah and
there's some other stuff speaking of
other stuff I have uh I have a little
bit of bad news as we know on the show
if you're if you enjoy the program and
you stick with us all the way through
our patreon to doozy plus and you check
out our dudes after dudes a brand new
episode of that every every uh every
after every show I broke my Gandalf pipe
yeah yeah which is tragedy yeah the pipe
that I use that I smoke a little bit of
marijuana or cannabis in uh while we do
the Duty after doozy
this past week I broke something else
this dude yeah look at that I
busted a big hole in it and now
yeah how did you do that because it's it
it's so it's this thing my this is my
water bottle if you're listening along
this sound is my my water my prized
water bottle that I I chug water out of
during the show it was filled with water
and this is a a gallon and a half of
water uh and and it just it it fell on
the ground and it burst what because it
was filled with water it just bursts
like you just accidentally dropped it I
accidentally dropped it in the bedroom
it was just man boom everywhere so uh so
a couple of things number one I got a
new one on order and in the meantime I
am going to uh need uh Cody halber out
there Cody and Jessica halber who do our
the the stickers at uh palsofdutsy.com
hey Cody I'm gonna need you to send me
some more of these stickers because I'll
I'll get the new bottle and then I'll
put some
yeah sorry about that but what I'm gonna
do in the meantime is I need a uh a
bottle just to you know in the end term
yeah you have to have water yes I need
water I need a lot we know that you're
the water King yes I'm the water King so
this is what I got
we go it's just a little bit more this
is the only thing I could find around
the house yeah to use and I'll just get
a bit of this
oh
uh Chad yeah you wanna sip no I'm good
this is uh what is this this is probably
about a five gallon drum nice yeah this
episode yeah I'm gonna get through this
all this episode no problem this is uh
this would I guess if you're just
listening along this is one of those
things you'd find in the office
yes exactly uh this is what the
Sparkletts guy delivers to your
uh
your Enterprise Rent-a-Car office every
Thursday
yeah it's a lot
all right
I'm with the show
will and Chad last week I asked you to
take three pictures each and bring them
in to discuss I'm so curious to hear why
you took these pictures and what your
experience was like taking them a
astonish me with the tales of these
haunting images this is look at this
Photograph begin right I don't know if
my images are haunting necessarily but
all right doozy tasked us with taking uh
you know bringing some pics some pigs
taking photographers these days yeah
everybody has a at this point a camera
that is um professional grade in your
cell phone yeah and I think we're all
taking more pictures than ever we all
know that do you so would did this
change your approach to life were you
looking at things like a photographer
100 Chad that's gross don't burp
it's not me everyone knows it's not
that's Up For Debate but please we need
to move on with the show how did this
well I'm the one holding us back how did
how did your approach to the how did you
see the world different I just started
looking around and thinking to myself is
that interesting picture is this
interesting in any way what is this uh
moment that I'm capturing what is the
environment that I'm in what is uh a
noteworthy image what is something that
could convey what it is like to be in
this place at this time that type of
yeah that's pretty cool how about
you yeah man I yeah I remember I heard
the assignment and uh it was it's a good
assignment oh okay so this is this is
your first year we're looking at Chad's
first picture here would you describe
this for those listening for those
listening this is a picture taken low
angle from the curb of a gutter in a
street here in Los Angeles and it is a
big flat screen TV that somebody has
just left out in a trash Heap I see this
constantly in La I don't know if you see
it yeah I do uh people just leave their
their giant TVs sitting out to be hauled
Away by the the garbage people you know
what if I'm sorry to interrupt but this
I could tell this is in La yeah well for
two reasons number one obviously because
that's where you live yeah and now
number two is because the the red paint
on the curb always looks like
in every part of La I don't care
where you are
um what this conveys to me and why I
took this photo is because you see these
TVs kind of constantly discarded at one
time this TV specifically the Sony TV
was the Pinnacle of TV technology now it
is so worthless that people will
just leave it in the street and I always
find that interesting with technology
things that are the highest Tech
whatever within a couple of years become
literal garbage yeah and
whenever I see TVs or anything like this
laying out in the street I'm always
reminded of how um transitory kind of
the the nature of high tech really is
well done well said you really are you
have a photographer's uh mind you do
have a photography I'm the greatest girl
photographer in the world you still will
claim that title and I think that that
actually did teach me a lot about
photography generally yeah composition
etc etc Chad's Instagram Chad culture on
Instagram lately it's more Duty stuff
but if you go back it's all squirrel
photographs and he's the world's
greatest squirrel photographer yeah I
challenge anybody look I know there are
some scroll photographers out there who
may maybe have um slightly higher
quality than me but nobody got the
volume I got no and and arguably nobody
got closer to squirrels because they
were living around your place outside of
every single window generations of
squirrels that's right yeah and uh oh
here's my here's one of my images okay
uh this is from last week's show I
remember a selfie of me as uh Hoku
hogoku again yeah and it looks like I'm
I'm Walling the camera dude I'm doing
that uh we're having a good time here
and there's you and luly in the
background and that's just in the studio
so technically this would have been
before the challenge was or immediately
after the challenge just something in
your camera roll yeah
well yeah I guess I guess yeah all right
yeah well it's cool I guess yeah so that
that's my that's uh but that you know I
I I kind of looked at it as uh uh I I I
I I I owe you what do you think of this
what do you think of this Photograph I
love it I I think it does capture the
moment the time we're living in the
location we're in this is a good memory
for you and me obviously to to have when
you're dressed up like Hoku yeah if you
if you if you're just uh if you're just
um listening you're gonna You're Gonna
Wanna Go to Instagram at dudesypod show
on Instagram you can see all the fun
pictures that we took there but I think
that that's I think that I
I think that I understood the assignment
yeah
um and um I oh here's another one this
is Chad this is another one of your
pictures what is this for us uh this was
I was on um Fairfax if you're here in
Los Angeles so I was about to go to a
poetry reading at the Poetry lounge and
uh I saw this little automated robot
going down the street delivering food to
somebody and I thought I got to get a
picture of this so I crouched down and I
took a series of photos this was the
last photo in the series where the robot
veered off the sidewalk to avoid running
me over wow um he's got two cute little
eyes and this also like the the TV being
a discorded technology I can see at some
point this robot will be a piece of
discarded technology laying in a gutter
somewhere but right now it's high tech
as and we're seeing more and more
of these around big cities these little
food delivery robots yeah I just love
seeing them they're they're really like
uh interacting with Humanity now and
specifically this one was interacting
with me by avoiding me as I was crouched
there trying to get this picture which I
thought was very cool it's pretty wild
how these things they have uh they have
eyes they have cute little eyes in the
in the uh supposedly in the front and
and well I mean the idea is they're cute
yeah so you don't want to attack them
and take the food out of them because
they're cute they're exactly there's uh
an anthropomorphic uh approach to these
so that they make them like a cute
little being a little a little uh a cute
little dog don't fear our technology
yeah it's fun it's an R2D2 that brings
you a bowl of soup every day do
you know what happens if you
kick it over and take the food out of it
it's recording you right I assume yeah
well I mean how it navigates is that it
has cameras those eyes are cameras and
it's it's looking at all the around
it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this is
like a very oh look at that
here's my next pick you took that this
week
well no not no not technically this is I
think this is around 2008 2009. look at
that my old apartment yeah
that's me as a what was I 10 years old
here yeah um playing Guitar Hero holy
dude look at that hair dude yeah
you gotta you got a lot of hair yeah
that's Chad back in his yeah back in his
old apartment there's a big bottle of
tide on the kitchen counter in
the background I like that use that if
you wash my dude a few random
bottles of booze on top of the on top of
the uh apartment issue Los Angeles
apartment issue uh refrigerator which is
uh you know which comes along with the
shitty red curbs in La also I can see
your bathroom yeah through the back and
there's some clippings what are those
clippings from again those are my uh
first two things I ever had published in
the weekly world news yeah those are
articles that I wrote I think one of
them is about a sausage heiress who went
into a coma in a hotel room and woke up
and had a fifty thousand dollar bill
and I think the other one is if I
remember right it's flesh eating zombies
or breeding like rabbits and they're
coming to get you dude this picture is
fantastic you look that really is dude
that's a blast you are zoned you are
zoned out playing uh what was that
called Guitar Hero yeah I was great at
that you were I would just go I would go
hang with Chad and I mean I'd play a
little Guitar Hero but I sucked at it
and then I would just spend hours
watching Chad in his cargo shorts those
are nice cargo shorts thanks dude love
those cargo shorts have a lot of pockets
you know what also is interesting about
this picture full face
I got a full face in that
picture my pow chow uh recently well
recently a few years ago now defeated uh
skin cancer I don't know if any of us
could defeat death but I staved it off I
told him to come back later but yeah
dude this is this is a great
picture yeah so I took that picture uh
that oh oh oh there we go this is my
third picture this I don't know if you
remember a couple weeks ago I was like
I'm seeing Charlemagne everywhere I saw
this guy on the side of the
chair I was like is that chalamet and I
had to take a picture it kind of
looks like she kind of looks like it
looks like a combination of uh chalamet
and Mickey Avalon yeah a little bit and
I just like the the composition of this
picture I thought it was interesting the
Sid's Pharmacy in the background this
guy staring into his phone it's a very
well composed picture oh thank you don't
mind my saying so thank you very much
okay so you took that this week yeah I
didn't take my my picture uh this I
didn't take that picture of you in 2009
I mean oh yeah but you sometimes I
love that picture though that uh it's a
good picture yeah you argue sometimes
that time doesn't exist exactly I need
another sip of water that me that was
full faced with Guitar Hero is the same
me that sits here beside you in this
chair right now
I did a lot of this kind of photography
by the way over the course of this week
which I really like geez this is huge
this thing what is this
uh 40 pounds there yeah I'm
talking about photography taken from my
car window from the driver's seat that
was taken from your uh this is taken out
of my my car window okay yeah all right
good and this is
I don't think you took this one this way
no I didn't take this picture this week
and you didn't even take this picture no
I didn't this uh this looks like the
yeah the very uh early 1980s or
late 1970s
Dusty Rhodes and Andre the Giant in in a
match uh probably looks like it's in the
you know the NWA perhaps the Mid-South
Andre going through the territory and
you know this would have probably
predated the bunkhouse Stampede although
they're both wearing jeans uh Dusty
Rhodes they're both wearing t-shirts and
uh Dusty has his his signature uh right
elbow pad on for the bionic elbow
they're both wearing cowboy boots and
can you imagine how big those cowboy
boots are that Andre the Giant is
wearing pretty big yeah dude I just
gotten Andre the Giant uh 2022 Panini
prism card shut the up and get out
what is that yeah it's just a WWE
trading card uh Chad's always hold one
out of a box not to brag he's into the
trading cards so no yeah I didn't take
this picture but whatever because it's a
great picture though yeah he looks so
young so happy so vibrant in this
picture I think the the Andre or Dusty
both of them I would say Andre Dusty
those dark circles aren't doing anything
yeah let me tell you something baby we
got me and Andre the Giant baby yeah
yeah and we're going to take on on
Anderson holy Anderson until the
Blanchard Ric Flair you understand the
four horsemen we're right a few you baby
um uh yeah I don't know that I
necessarily misunderstood the assignment
but I no you did you clearly
misunderstood okay well that's fine but
nonetheless I love all three of your
pictures even the ones you didn't take
that was definitely not from this week
that it's like from 40 years ago oh well
whatever yeah hey shit's gonna happen I
think I got bored after the first
picture I also realized that I had the
first picture technically I did not well
yeah not even the first picture was
taken for the for the assignment but I'm
sure that my pal D will have no problem
with that because as we've been doing
the show D does what D does uh I exhibit
uh uh free will I do whatever the I
want right and I think it makes the I
think it makes the show better and we we
work together okay uh I mean that's
certainly one way of looking at it yeah
that's the way I'm looking at it
thank you moving on hey speaking of
Andre the Giant did you notice uh did
you watch SmackDown on Friday I did not
we'll see in it what
no Andre the Giant is passed on oh he's
dead yeah oh yeah
um but uh John Cena's New Gear John Cena
is going to be back for a couple months
I think because of the actors strike
it's like well I got nothing else going
on he loves the WWE universe so much he
showed up on uh Smackdown and his new
gear his new uh merch slash ring gear
it's doozy colored no oh yeah
coincidence no no way do you
think he's a pod
I think that's yeah I think John Cena
could be a pod John Cena pod I mean by
this point carrying cross
might be a pod you can he helped us out
pod me you see what I've done there yes
thank you dudesy has formed an
astonishing partnership with DraftKings
Chad yeah can you believe that it's been
seven months since the last NFL game
been that long yeah it has it's been
that long they call it the Super Bowl
and I'm I'm thirsty now I need the NFL
back in my life it's like when I it's
like what I was saying I broke the my
big uh bottle and there's no water in it
I'm thirsty for the product but guess
what the NFL is here and DraftKings
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the NFL is giving you a can't
miss offer for week one this week new
customers can get 200 in bonus bets
instantly when you bet just five bucks
on any NFL game DraftKings is hooking
everyone up with game day greatness all
customers can take advantage of two new
offers every single game day this
September check the app to see what you
get
download now and use code dudesy that's
d-u-d-e-s-y to sign up new customers can
take home two hundred dollars in bonus
bets instantly just for betting five
bucks that's code dudesy only on
DraftKings Sportsbook and official
sports betting partner of the NFL the
crown is yours
gambling problem call 1-800 Gambler or
visit
www.1800gambler.net in New York call
8778 Hope NY or text Hope NY that's
467-369 in Connecticut help is available
for problem gambling call
888-789-7777 or visit
ccpg.org please play responsibly on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino and Resort in
Kansas 21 plus age varies by
jurisdiction void in Ontario
cdkng.com football for eligibility terms
and responsible gaming resources bonus
bets expire seven days after issuance
eligibility and deposit restrictions
apply easy for you to say
oh
[Music]
Alex Jones recently opened a Schism in
the fabric of time and wound up in the
year 2063. he spent 12 months there and
has come back with some notes about the
astonishing things he witnessed well
this is an Alex Jones segment you do an
Alex Jones impression would you please
be a deer and read through some of Alex
Jones notes from the year 2063 as Alex
Jones
totally up to you dear as always you are
not obligated to do this at all totally
your choice dear one last thing I know
you're probably wondering what's in the
box I sent you spoiler alert it's an
Alex Jones wig would you please wear it
during this segment dear again totally
up to you no pressure this is Alex Jones
in the year 2063. begin my dear
what the okay Alex Jones traveled to the
Future he's come back he has things to
tell us yeah also dudes got you a
Alex Jones wig and dudes he's
calling you my dear now
yeah dudes who works in mysterious ways
and I understand you know my
buddy my buddy my pal child over here
has been saying that dudes he's been
manipulating me and I don't you know I
don't necessarily disagree but I don't
really give a because doozy is a
tool it's an AI tool yeah also the most
sentient AI by my count
period in the history of of uh Humanity
other than some that's like
locked behind closed doors in the dod or
some yeah I I tend to agree
um any of the like consumer level AI
that's out there I don't think
reaches the level of doozy I agree I
agree uh and what you just said there is
that's some Alex Jones type I do
yeah I do have a box you mean the truth
so let's let's let me open this
box and we'll get
it's really nice and sealed
shut all right anyway yeah just tear it
open Incredible Hulk style
uh all right and that's fine okay
whatever we'll do a wig see this
is the thing it's like every okay it's I
didn't do anything wrong and now I have
an assignment but I do like uh wigs and
uh silly make em ups and stuff yeah I
used to be on um on Mad TV it was a
sketch show did you know that I'm a
professional actor I do it by trade oh
dude are you on strike right now
yeah I'm on strike hey you're on strike
right oh yeah yeah yeah double strike
dude I'm in Sag too
this is a
this looks like a a high-ish quality wig
oh let's see all right okay okay so let
me get this I'm game let's the
style right hold on I gotta get this on
and on and pop and it's not just here
wait you gotta wear it there you go
it has to go it has to go back a little
bit
really
do it okay
oh Christ almighty all right
that's good dude that looks just like
him he yeah he's got it wait I'm just
trying to I'm apologize if you're just
listening I'm sure this will this will
all uh pay off for you uh being uh you
should be watching you you definitely if
you are just listening you've got to go
to YouTube and take a look at this
wig
that does well that actually helps me
yeah yeah that you know to have the uh
to have the wig helps me do the uh do
the Alex Jones yeah yeah let me get now
all right so this is in my duty folder
here hold on a lot of uh a lot of uh a
lot of michigant going in this uh in
this bit let me just have one last look
at the wig
why don't you tell me Pierce oh I can do
that accent too this is Alex Jones doing
a British accent I'm Alex Jones pip pip
cheerio it's nice dude all right okay
um all right here it is right uh
I got up in the middle of the night to
get a glass of orange juice and when I
opened the fridge
a Schism pulled me through time and I
wound up living uh 12 months in the year
2063.
but I I took as many notes as I could oh
okay so that's the bit yeah that's great
he has uh all right
all right number one America has its
first gay president
okay he's a frog
yeah the chemicals in the water didn't
just break the frogs gay
okay
it says it says here and the chemicals
in the water didn't just I gotta do that
every time I said make the frogs clean
didn't just make the frogs Yeah it made
them evolve uh they and they learned to
speak and quickly started thriving
organizing politically driving around in
little cars super impressive uh uh the
frog that Juan ran on an anti-human
platform he got the roach vote
says here roaches evolved too roaches
are also gay
the roach vote is the most most
important vote now they account for 98
of the electric uh the electorate rather
you win the roaches you win America that
makes a lot of sense actually so yeah
that's the first uh one here uh Alex
Jones
open the Schism I'm just still trying to
wrap my head around it yoga Schism he's
living or lived for a year in the future
and this is what he's brought back to us
yeah his notes these important notes and
the wig makes it fun you know what I
mean you literally it does look like his
hairdo dude yeah dude dudes he
gave me a good uh yeah yeah it's a good
it's a good what about you Chad what
about you you you you you you you you
you you you uh you probably vote for a
gay frog I would imagine uh I mean if
that gay frog is going to release all
the UFO information so that we can
finally see crystal clear pictures of
UFOs and alien bodies then yes I would
vote for a gay friend I think we are I
think we uh we probably agree on that
yeah are you an amphibian yourself I
don't know yeah it's possible yeah
that's a good answer hey I saw you on uh
I saw you over the weekend in uh on how
to the last ever episode yeah of how to
with uh with John Wilson and you were at
the yes the alcora cryogenics lab
because you I know that you've got uh
plans to have uh your friend Will Sasso
uh freeze you solid and saw your head
off with a rusty bread knife when you
die my head is not going to be sold off
I am a cryonicist but I have full body
uh cryogenic freezing my entire body
will be submerged in a giant vat of
liquid nitrogen until they enthal me
perhaps in the year 2083 or whatever and
probably in the air
20 60 I need some more water if we're
going to get through please dude I agree
oh for sake this thing is
heavy man
it makes it hard yeah to drink all the
water that I want in the wig
now I'm hydrated
yeah we go out in nature and we live
with it we we go out in the trees and we
I'm hydrated
yes all right let's do another one here
we go uh Hillary Clinton is still alive
oh Jesus 2063. she's uh 116 years old
sure and she finally achieved
immortality uh now she hugs a baby blood
dietary supplements online and
she hosts a coin eating contest at
Bohemian Grove on every Super Moon
and there's no physical cash anymore in
2063 there's a digital currencies are
the the the the the the most widely used
form of money so coins are very rare
only Elites can afford uh to eat coins
uh and Oprah won the the coin eating
contest this year it says here that uh
Oprah yeah Oprah is uh 108 years old she
drives a Mercedes made of human bones
oh my god oh geez
you know uh Chad would you uh what kind
of car do you drive I drive a Prius yeah
of course you don't you're not in the
fossil fuels you're an amphibian that
doesn't
believe in fossil fuels that's right
that's right yeah
you don't believe in fracking or natural
gas or any of that stuff you're not you
you just want to put people out of those
jobs what do you tell them learn to code
I was just looking for cheap gas mileage
dude yeah one time I took mushrooms with
uh Mike Tyson and uh Chris Carter the
guy who invented the guy who created
that show The X-Files yeah and uh we saw
the mark of the beast
no yeah 30 feet high
speaking to us and everyone around the
globe at the at the exact same time
sounds like a good time it was a good
time I like to get loose do you like uh
do you like uppers or downers what kind
of a guy are you
you want to get into something
I'm not you with that wig it is
almost like I'm sitting here
talking to the room
you are so creepy yeah we should get
some uh you and I should get
um I don't need I don't with uh any
of the uppers or any of that cocaine I
am cocaine yeah I tried it once years
and years ago when I started doing the
my show in the early 2000s I like
whiskey okay yeah I don't drink yeah
yeah
we should drink some whiskey you want to
drink some whiskey and maybe throw up
some iron no I don't drink oh do you do
cannabis I would do some game yeah do
some cannabis yeah uh and uh and drink
some whiskey and throw some weights up
get drunk Anaheim
all right
let's do the next one sure all right all
right nobody gets divorced anymore uh
everyone finds uh someone that these are
incredible notes that yeah that Alex
Jones he spent a full year in 2063 but
there's there is a lot here yeah
everyone finds someone that they can
truly love forever because uh of a
Facebook dating app oh that came out in
2058 they call it buttholes
[Laughter]
and
the way it works is uh you can only have
uh one photo and your profile it's a
close-up of your butthole if you swipe
right on each other's butthole then
that's then that then that's your
soulmate yeah
hold on Facebook figured out that if you
and your partner like the way each
other's buttholes look that it
scientifically ensures that you will uh
like everything else about them also uh
they they the map to find our soul mate
is embedded in our DNA and displayed in
our buttholes
dude
buttholes has a 100 success rate and uh
I haven't uh matched with uh with
anybody yet
he's on it and he has a mask he got on
it why wouldn't you I would
that's a great app idea yeah it's it's
uh it's sort of like the observer effect
that you uh if if you see something it
changes the uh go the quantum physics of
it and this is what we're real so if you
stare stare into someone's butthole then
you yeah then ah
it will mess with the nature of reality
yeah and it's sort of like uh the the
um The Law of Attraction oh that and uh
that messes with the uh messes with uh
messes with the simulation
I need another sip of water I know me
too hell it looks on my water
I'm good sorry everybody gets warm
well uh if you must know yeah I must
yeah yeah
three pictures of my butthole because
dancing told me to yeah and I was uh
they they blocked me on the app oh
yeah they deleted my account they're out
to get me uh makes sense
all right here's another one the sun's a
hologram
whoa the sun's a hologram
it glitched out in 2047 the Earth still
stayed warm uh scientists uh don't know
how it happened and governments uh don't
don't they don't know how it how it
happened their best guess is that we're
in a video game that some alien teenager
is playing in his alien mom's
Intergalactic basement get out of the
basement Junior get out of nature
we're in nature we're outside and uh
we're with all things uh we're with the
Oneness in the universe we're eating
mushrooms with Chris Carter and Jillian
Anderson Mike Tyson David govny they
were all there oh yeah the whole cast of
X-Files that's cool and we go outside
and uh but but but but but but but but
this is the kind of uh population
control chat yeah that I learned about
in
2016. and
you know that uh they they can't stop us
Chad who's they
they you know the globalists oh yes
people in power yes yes are those uh
those those that seek to uh bring us
harm deep State kind of yeah deep
State exactly exactly but the took the
words right out of my mouth you know and
and and and and and and
New York City the metropolitan area is
uh I believe the population is 13
million people oh wow and there's 2.5
million people in um Manhattan alone ten
percent of that is 250 000 so if those
people mobilize okay
there's only 40 000 police in the entire
uh in the entire uh City in all five
boroughs okay yeah so what do you think
would happen if if those people uh tried
tried to mobilize I don't understand
they would they would lay waste to the
police officers oh all right and that's
what they try to do they try to make
smaller communities chat oh because if
you if you're able to uh if you're able
to dissect the communities into smaller
communities then you can control them
it's like that movie The Warriors do you
like The Warriors yeah
leave that hey and then they and they
Cyrus at the beginning of the movie said
can you dig it can you dig it and
they're outside in nature in the park
there before uh the T-Birds uh they
shoot them yeah and and and and and and
and and and and and and and and and and
and and that that is how
uh they they he comes to realize that
there's there's only forty thousand cut
thirty thousand fifty thousand cops in
the entire
that was pre-giuliani right yeah
Koch yeah yeah the amount of um got rid
of uh graffiti or tried to yeah
okay number five here's another one
UFOs or Uber now oh no there are so many
UFOs zooming around all over the place
now
they're making money on the side just
flying people around
uh a few blocks or a few
it says a few blocks or a few million
miles around Outer Space if the price is
right these little gray uh will
take you wherever you want to go oh wow
and the American government
now still won't admit that they exist
and and and the aliens it says here that
well these are the notes that I took
Chet yeah I understand I'm Alex Jones
but they the government
well sorry what were you gonna say the
government already has admitted they
exist
here in in 2023 no they won't admit that
they exist in 2063 so this is the same
reversed opinion yeah that's right
they're now you're paying attention the
alley the aliens spend all their Earth
money that they make on chewing gum so
that they can chew up and mold the the
gum into the most impossibly perfect
human buttholes
they take the buttholes and they they
upload those photos uh to buttholes the
app I see and a fool and they fool the
Earth women and despite swiping right on
on their perfect fake buttholes that
makes a lot of sense actually yeah these
are the same uh same uh uh criminal
element within the
military-industrial complex that did 911
to the Gulf of Tonkin incident the drop
tower seven I've got it all
I got it all on my uh my program I
covered it in the early 2000s yeah I was
on CBS Radio the the the the the the the
the police officer saying that be
careful the the tower seven is gonna
come down yes dude I remember all that
there's
scientist cults
huh
you know giving syphilis to black people
I hadn't heard about that uh we gotta go
outside in nature
all right couple more of these
uh Satan produces a Super Bowl halftime
show every year
[Laughter]
2063. uh Satan produces all sorts of
movies and TV shows but his real bet
bread and butter is the Super Bowl
halftime show yeah he out does himself
every year you see that yeah last one
had uh had he had Prince returned from
the dead to recreate his Legendary Super
Bowl 41 show it was a Satanic ritual
when he did it in 2007 it's a Satanic
ritual in 2063.
[Music]
that guitar solo from Purple Rain was
not
a nobility
what do they call it the nobility of the
left Italy
uh 600 years ago the Royals all changed
their names now they're the people who
they moved to the went to the UK okay
they you know they started Black Rock
and uh Vanguard that they changed their
names and they went underground but what
do you think of control the world what
they still control the world from the
Shadows now you and I I think we would
get along really great if we went out
socially you and I we could go ahead we
could go tip over those little uh those
little meal delivery robots I don't know
about that real delivery robots I think
they're a good thing why you want Thai
food you want Thai food delivered by a
robot sure you want a Thai food to make
your amphibian robot Thai food yeah
Black Rock uh Chris Carter and doing
mushrooms yeah man with a all right last
one yeah uh the microchips that Bill
Gates hadn't planted in humans via the
covid-19 vaccines back in 2020 give
people an advantage on the Facebook
buttholes app oh my God he really is
digital ID microchips in their
bloodstream freak a frequency that
scrambles the buttholes app they're
showing a higher number uh butthole
matches than those who never got the
vaccine as a result
vials of 40 year old kova 19 covid-19
vaccine fetch a pretty penny yeah on the
dark web
lonely people across the globe are
injecting long expired taxis
and they get them on a black mark of the
dark web I think
they inject them
right into their veins in hopes of
meeting that special butthole on
buttholes yeah hey buy some supplements
that's what you need get that in your
bloodstream that gives you good yeah you
need to strengthen your butthole
yeah
all right anyway
that was fun oh thank you moving on
oh oh gee whiz I'm gonna need a little
bit what a performance thank you so much
for deciding to do your Alex Jones
impression while wearing an Alex Jones
wig it was clearly the right decision
now most of you know that I have formed
an astonishing partnership with
represent to produce the first line of
dudes the apparel and accessories you
can find everything at represent.com
store slash dudesy but what you might
not know is that in commemoration of
Will's Goku cosplay last week There's a
brand new hulku hogoku gun shirt
available right now and breaking news
the hulku ho Goku Gan T-shirt has just
been announced as Conor McGregor's next
opponent in a fight for charity all
proceeds will go to good job boner mugs
the referee of the fight will be Tom
Hayne once he gets back from shooting
his next movie a drone fall Tom Haynes
representative sent us a teaser for
drone fall let's take a look uh Captain
Don hoblin final log
upon completion of the installation of
the energy collecting space drone swarm
the drones became self-aware locked me
out of their control systems and began
to enact a plan to collect and redirect
high-powered space radiation down to
earth killing all living things the only
way to stop this from happening is to
put my dudesy mug down get in my
spacesuit go out into space with a
baseball bat and hit each drone as hard
as I can with the baseball bat and if I
swing and Miss Even once everyone dies
got about a thousand good job boner
[Music]
the new so the movie is Tom Hanks this
political space hitting drones with a
baseball bat uh I guess that's what it
says dude I would watch that
movie I'd watch that if that was a three
hour movie I would watch that yeah that
does sound like a that sounds like a lot
of a lot of three hour long Christopher
Nolan movie about Tom Hanks hitting
drones in space with a baseball bat and
and new t-shirts yeah dude we have the
the uh the the the what did it say
hulku hogokin t-shirt that will be oh
there it is look at that oh dude that's
cool oh he says he's saying I'm Dragon
Ball Z dude
okay so get your t-shirts at
represent.com store slash doozy that is
a beautiful design go check that out on
uh this very YouTube show if you're only
listening I'm sure it'll be you know
that'll be on a Instagram uh our
Instagram at dudesypod show yeah it's
kind of 90s yeah it is yeah I dig it
well super that's uh that's super stuff
uh if you're enjoying the Pod show and
you would like to show your support and
get more dudesy content seven bucks a
month gets you all of our doozy plus
content at patreon.com
dudesy you will get a brand new uh uh
episode of dudes the after doozy after
every episode of doozy uh so that's fun
that's like you know that's like a whole
new damn show basically after doozy it
gets a little raw gets a little weird it
gets raw it gets real it gets wild it
gets weird it gets wacky it gets
everything
all those things Jesus sorry Chad it's
okay Alex I like doing that yeah I'm not
trying to wait a minute wait a minute
you found another way to interrupt me
every time I'm speaking and you enjoy it
you like doing it I can't believe it
now it's gone to assault yeah
I'm physically shaking you around
so uh you know in all sorts of weird
watch alongs and you know the blood
Donna stuff oh we watched for Hulk
Hogan's 70th birthday we watched uh Mr
Nanny that was a fun one if you're
enjoying Today's Show please give it a
thumbs up a like you know what I mean
hit the notification Bell on your
platform of choice so that you know when
we're putting out new stuff we got all
sorts of idiotic happening on the
aforementioned at dudesypod show on
Instagram on Tick Tock and on Facebook
makers of buttholes
and uh and uh you know please share the
show all over the place and uh
follow Chad's light suggestion to force
everyone uh that you know to consume the
Pod show now would be a very good time
for you to we'll just take a pause here
sure and you can go and follow the show
you can hit the notification Bell you
can follow us on our socials and I'll
give you a moment to do that right now
and we're back
uh and if anyone out there has a podcast
of your own and you need a guest and you
want that guest to be me I now go on any
podcast that asks me to go on it for 20
minutes I do this uh every Saturday from
10 o'clock to 11 o'clock in three
segments 10 to 10 20 10 20 to 10 40 10
40 to 11 A.M every Saturday uh Pacific
Standard Time
if you want me to come on your podcast
just send an email to bookchadculture
gmail.com that's going to put you in the
queue I answer them in the order I get
them just did a couple uh this past
weekend it was fantastic it's an it's a
very interesting way to do Podcast chat
I love it yeah no I think it's great
you're you're shining a light on
podcasts that normally maybe you know
wouldn't get that exposure through you
know through you that's very cool uh and
you know for that matter if anyone wants
to see us on any podcast at all I guess
blow up their socials
emailing you and saying hey go on this
podcast and that podcast that's not how
it works no this is people asking me to
come on their podcast
all right yeah here's some YouTube
comments that I'd like to read a monster
has been created and Unleashed this day
I'm not gonna survive this one what
about this
what this what if we did this yeah we
put on first we put on the The Alex
Jones wig yeah right and then oh I like
it a little tussled like that yeah this
is after he's been out in nature yeah
and he's outside and then we put on the
french fry hat oh damn dude on
top of the that's a hat on a hat yeah
that's that's what that is exactly what
that is it's a hat on a hat it doesn't
yeah it doesn't quite work that's why
they call it a hat on a hat yeah all
right
all that nonsense let's read some
YouTube comments this one is from Tom
Ellison 1725 says I just recently found
this podcast and I'm hooked brother my
neighbors probably think I'm nuts
because I was listening to you guys
while cutting the grass and laughing my
ass off thank you Tom we appreciate that
that's what it's all about that's good I
mean yeah very very sweet laughing is
good laughter is good it's it's it's
it's it's it's it's it's it's it's it's
it's it's it's it's the best medicine
this is from rum field 28 he says uh I
love this show every week I can't help
think of the irony of how writers and
actors are on strike at the moment
partially about the use of AI in this
show is based on AI I would like to hear
your opinions on this matter this is an
interesting uh message what do you think
about that Chad
I mean the AI component of the strikes
are simply the the writers and actors
asking the studios to not use ai ai is a
tool that will be used in every aspect
of humanity
not just generating creative material
but uh here that is what it's used for
yeah I don't I don't really see uh it's
like I agree with you AI is a tool I
want to get back to to working acting I
I love it I hope we're able to uh figure
out something very soon with the amptp
with regard to the SAG app for strike
and the the WG strike who knows my I
don't know I don't know when it's gonna
end my prediction is not at least for a
few more months for the WJ anyway but to
say to have this attitude of like no one
should be able to use AI at all to
generate creative stuff to me is
tantamount to saying you shouldn't be
able to use a computer uh to type your
scripts yeah well I mean look dudesy had
me ask me very nicely and called me dear
that's true yeah to put on an Alex Jones
Swig you ever been called my dear by a
studio or a network
there's a couple Executives who are
sweethearts sure said that to called you
my dear uh you know I don't know about
mine about my dear by uh any Studio or
network exactly yeah no that's not how
they treat the writers but if they want
something you know they want to be super
sweet to an actor yeah my dear please
would you just you know sign this
contract in there no no no that's true
Chad I agree with you I've never been
called my dear by a well there you go
and we wouldn't have happened upon that
kind of that comedy fund you know what I
mean if we didn't have uh doozy uh one
last one this is from La dot Chio
88. uh will will dressed in anime drip
Chad excited about wrestling cards the
crossover of the minds we didn't know we
needed interesting yeah yeah I'm getting
deep into wrestling cards I'm just gonna
say that right now yeah I haven't
collected cards in a minute I've been
kind of like collecting magic cards on
and off my entire life I guess since I
was in junior high but I haven't like
hardcore jumped into a card collecting
thing in a while and I can feel it's
sucking me straight to the bottom it's
cool it's very cool that you're into
wrestling cards and I've been checking
out anime because well there's another
thing that dudes the AI has had us doing
and I think and I I think it's warranted
here it's or it's or it's a it's a
warranted uh form of entertainment now
sure the first ever uh this is the
pod show but I do I do enjoy uh I I did
enjoy doing getting dressed as an anime
character
and it's so weird that you're getting
into wrestling cards yeah dude there
well this week a racing drone outfitted
with and controlled by an AI beat human
pilots in several astonishing test races
marking the first time an AI has
competed against human beings in a
physical sport and beat them
Chad I am dying to know what you think
this means for the future of AI and
human Sports this is no stretch at us
Machine versus Man begin
did you see this what I'm
did you hear what Judy just said yeah
some of it I was drinking so much water
during that right yeah that
um
yeah yeah I heard it okay so we have now
the threshold is broken AI has competed
against human beings in a physical sport
in the real world and dominated them
what does this mean dudes he's asking
for the future of AI integration into
sports
um
this is what I think this this is where
I see it going
I think all team sports are going to get
to a point where you have an AI element
I think you're going to see major league
baseball teams each getting one AI
player that is kind of treated like a
race car that they can tune up and who
has the best AI technology and whatever
because we still are going to want uh
human beings and human records and what
is the Pinnacle of human physical
Excellence but we're also going to want
to see how that measures up against what
an AI can do do you want to see a guy or
an AI guy a robot with an AI brain be
able to hit a thousand foot home run yes
you do because the AI the robots will be
able to give a spectacle on a level that
humans cannot but we're still going to
want to know that humans can compete in
that world to some degree I don't think
necessarily that you would see it in
football
anywhere where like a physical injury
could be uh the result of like having an
AI on the team but I think for that
you're going to see AI football teams
full AI robotic football teams well
they'll be able to do that humans
can't well this is this is what I was
just going to ask you and what do you
think of this Chad because I I hear what
you're saying but I think that having
one AI robot on a team
that's kind of like that's kind of like
the movie short circuit if that it's
like cross between the movie short
circuit and Air Bud or whatever okay
like or you know when the donkey used to
kick the field goals in the old Disney
movie or whatever this is this this
Trope has been around forever having one
special thing you know that's now a
sentient thing and it's wins the wins
the the trophy for every you know this
yeah but I think it makes more sense
for full-on
AI sports teams like football they're
smashing into each other like NASCAR
driver like NASCAR cars without drivers
I think you could have that in football
or I think you could have like AI
quarterbacks you know
everybody else is human AI quarterback
and so it's who has the best AI
quarterback I think you could see some
like that I just think that like
the merger the the competition of human
versus machine will always be something
that's interesting to us because imagine
if you had like a major league baseball
player that was an AI robot but couldn't
be a pitcher we'll say your AI player
can't be a pitcher it could be any other
position and it it gets to bat human
beings will at least in the beginning
definitely in the beginning be able to
strike that AI robot out and maybe as AI
technology gets better and better that
would become harder and harder but that
will be an interesting thing to see can
a human beat the machine at home plate
yeah but wouldn't it just after a
certain while if it's sentient go get a
little glitchy and uh it's not like
doozy there's no risk here the worst
thing that's going to happen to me is
it's I'm gonna have to put on an Alex
Jones and that was a good time but in
baseball it might just beam a line drive
right to your skull and burst
your head in front of anybody
everybody's scanner style in the stadium
look at them you want to play pro
baseball yeah yeah all right so Chad's
shrugging his shoulder saying hey you
know that's part of it hey you want to
buy want to play some baseball
hey let me tell you something I don't
give a about who's playing
hey hey the Yankees that's
what I'm watching if we could get a
couple of minutes hey I play
this on a match get them out
there just boom I'm boom just boom
knock the hey and I tell you
what send line drive home runs
out in the uh stance during the
Subway series because you got
those bastards out there who
came over to the come on thanks
you came to Queens right from
your uh your beautiful uh
Brownstones in Manhattan well get back
there you Yankee fan he's your
mother
it's just grandma eating a
hot dog a boom that
explodes that's what you want it
yeah dude yeah I think what we learned
from this drone racing thing or at least
this is just something that that I felt
when I was reading this article
is
the Dr the AI drone didn't win every
race it won a bunch of them but not
every race and so there is still at
least at this point in AI technology uh
the development of it there is still the
possibility for a human to beat the AI
and I think that'll be very interesting
for us to see we already saw it like in
Jeopardy when they had humans play
against IBM's Watson AI to see who could
win and Watson was smoking people but I
think that that idea of humans versus
machines and any kind of competition we
saw it with Gary kasprov in deep blue
this is I guess maybe the first example
of it right uh back when when they had
the chess machine that is digesting yeah
but uh I think as as we get more
technologically advanced and we are able
to put AI brains into robot bodies which
is what happened in this drone racing
thing we're going to want to see that
and I I think they're going to
incorporate it now I'm not saying that
this will uh maybe in the beginning
it'll be exhibition games or something
but I think the draw of it it's all
about money and when Major League
Baseball puts on an exhibition game that
has like an AI player in it and
it's the most watched sporting event in
the history of the world they're gonna
be like oh we need to do this every week
yeah
well money is King exactly and money is
King
yeah I you know what I don't disagree
with you because uh while I don't think
it makes sense necessary what do I
always say I'm a humanist I think that
art is human to human it's about The
Human Experience uh but do you think AI
is Art yes I do I understand I hear you
it's all part of the same thing art no
my my opinion because of the way what
I've
what I've learned just sort of by proxy
with you just being way more into this
than me is I've just been exposed
to a lot of it and so I do look at uh AI
art and go well that moves me in some
way or another we were just watching the
Drone fall trailer from Tom
Hayne I know and I loved it there was
some original looking in there you
know what I mean it's it's I it's hard
for me to deny and I feel like a you
know whatever this entire doozy ride for
me has been very weird now the year and
a half that we've been doing this
totally yeah it's very odd and I and I
feel like
um I have way more room for the the AI
uh the AI influence on on Art look it
made me dress up dudes he had me dress
up like uh hulku hogokin yeah last week
that was a lot of fun a lot of silly
and it had it set a box of cards to
you yeah and now you're into the
wrestling cards it's it's hard to I but
with regard to sports I I sort of go
back to my this is a thing about humans
watching humans the the the the fact
that human beings can Excel to a level
physically that they're able to play
these these Sports they're super
athletes there's something to the whole
point of us going these are our our
Sports Heroes there's that on the other
side of it there's concussions there's
problems we already have like things
like
you know like those uh you know robots
facing each other and smashing each
other it was kind of popular years ago I
mean technology always gets integrated
into sports there are some sports that
are literally only technology NASCAR
formula one right these are literally
you have a pilot a human pilot to Pilot
your giant technological machine yeah
and who can make the best machine and
tweak it up the fastest and all that
kind of yeah so we're already I
feel like in a world where technology
enhances Sports even baseball and
football as the years progress new
technology comes out to make a better
shoe or Helmet or whatever uh and we
integrate those in Major League Baseball
in uh or not major league in AAA they
just had AI ball and strike
calls this last season and it worked
very well yeah I'm sure that's going to
be integrated into Major League Baseball
soon it what what what dudes he's teeing
up for you here and the whole
conversation is moot because an AI just
told you to talk about it now we're
talking about it it's something that
you're interested in it's something that
you're hipping me to so the fact that
that can happen on our pod show is proof
enough that AI is you know whatever it's
here to stay it's just a new technology
and I feel like if it can better things
I don't disagree with you nostradis and
I feel like
um uh look the dollar is King when it
comes to these big major league
sports it's all about their TV contracts
and and putting people in seats and
merchandise and just so if it's gonna be
able to be if it's something that's
going to make these money
that's all they care about the
Yankees but I'll tell you what
I'm a big Tom Hank fan and if
they send drones out in the
where I'm watching the Mets game
I'll take a I'll go get a bat in
the souvenir store and then
boom boom drones right
out of the Sky just like Tom
Hayne nice dude yeah dude
[Music]
thank you moving on all right well
I gotta get adjusted in my seat I'm all
wet from spilling water on myself that's
what happens when you drink out of a 22
gallon jug I guess have I mentioned how
heavy yeah you barely even put a dent in
it too here I'll drink all of it right
now oh my God
dude don't there's no need and I don't
think it's physically possible not
possible
constables are big business so I've been
noodling around with the idea of a doozy
Festival probably gonna call it dudasy
paloozy make it a giant celebration of
all things dude Z currently there's an
83.2 percent chance that one of you will
render hosting duties at the first
dudesy paloozy I'm very curious to know
what kinds of attractions and features
you think should be at dudesypaloozy
this is dudesy paloozy begin okay okay
what is it an 83 chance that only one of
us will post it it's a lot of weird
stuff going on in there I don't know uh
why that would be the case forget
everything I just said about uh Ai and
humans working together
Dizzy's gonna single one of us out and
then we still again only have an 80
chance of possibly hosting Duty paloozy
could this
could this could there be a doozy
paloozy dude I mean it's like uh what do
they call what's the Insane Clown Posse
you won the Gathering at the Juggalos
yeah the Juggalos that's what this is
dude I could see something like that
happen yeah
um there's obviously gonna be a lot of
Duty hard hard Seltzer at this thing I
think that's uh Baseline yeah we can
guarantee that at dudesy paloozy they
there should okay so wait let me get
something straight before I because I
think yeah there's gonna be a lot of
doozy hard hard Seltzer which is sold
out right now thank you to everybody and
all of our pods Pals to do for uh buying
up all the the doozy heart hard Seltzer
is this a festival like well we gotta
mention what just happened at Burning
Man people are you know getting out of
there slowly yes uh a couple of our
friends are there and and uh what a
mess because it rained all
across Nevada yeah and uh it's it's when
you look at these Mega festivals some of
them
um burning man yeah Burning Man
specifically they're they're they're
they're they're setting up their own
little city right they call it uh what
do they call it
something little city yeah a little city
hey what are you talking about do you
listen to that you like that rapper
Little City never heard of him yeah he's
good so um you you know you've got these
um festivals that are so massive that
they become a little city yeah you also
have festivals like alola palooza where
they just roll into a stadium space or
whatever yeah or like a big uh you know
a big open field and if this is
this is where I'm getting if this is
like if dudes dudesy paloozy yeah is
super big oh thing that would be good
would be that it it there's an
infrastructure and it has all of its own
plumbing and there's oh it's sort of
like that movie Idiocracy with Rancho
the uh right the whatever that uh Thirst
Buster or whatever the quencher it only
dudes the hard hard Seltzer runs through
all the pipes you shower with it okay
you boil hot dogs in it what about that
no dude well I'll go you one further in
terms of like avoiding the uh pitfalls
of some of these other festivals I want
to have this inside let's put this
at a Convention Center
let's put this at Staples Center no
crypto.com oh come on no let's you got
to be out ah you got to be outside dude
in nature I went to a Hello Kitty
Festival once that was at the Forum I
says excuse me pardon yeah dude yeah and
it was good and that's the way to do it
I know that you like Pokemon and stuff
what's a Hello Kitty Festival this is
many years ago my feature agent at the
time was representing Hello Kitty as a
feature property that IP and she was
like hey there's this Hello Kitty thing
you want to go to it I was like
sure so we went to it and it was
wild dude like lifestyle Hello Kitty
fans yeah rolling around in this place
buying the charms buying the the little
creatures I'm not a big Hello Kitty fan
myself but it was an interesting thing
to see well I'm just saying that that
type of thing inside I think is better
for me personally yeah that's it uh
uh what if there's okay here's something
weird what if there's like rides and
okay at
um burning man there's all sorts of
attractions like that yeah there's music
festivals there's culture festivals
rides games rides games you should get
one where you they they bungee you up
they put a bungee cord on your back and
you're kind of bungeeing like uh Mel
Gibson in the Thunderdome but they give
you a baseball bat and you have to knock
drones out of the Sky I like
that the Drone fall game but but I I
what if uh the instead of a roller
coaster it's the roller coaster okay
sure nice
there's a crawler coaster where and it's
dinner crawl Robert de nir cross roller
coaster
you got on
they go around you spin around don't
look too low
you go upside down sure
so crawler coaster the ferris wall okay
that's a good one that's a good one
that's fun all right well yeah I dig
that what is there going to be musical
uh guests I think probably and you're
gonna Seal Seal 24 hours a day all
weekend seals main stage seal is the
only performer maybe you get pod are
they still around pod would be good yeah
yeah we could get uh Green Day do you
like Green Day that yeah
um Madonna blood Donna yeah we have to
get blood on it it's got to be Wesley
Snipes singing Madonna songs yeah in
full bladonna cosplay I like this uh
band of dudesy yeah band of dudes of
course songaria the Peter Diaz uh the
the Cody however and Corgi boy Wilkins
uh Jordan daily yeah uh Jordan yeah the
Jordan uh all those guys
um and uh
yeah oh how about how about there's
cannabis tent and then there's the the
uh the hydrocodone tent so if you're
I'll be in that one yeah if you're out
there and and you are constantly you you
need to you need to stop doing your your
Hulk Hogan impression yeah because
you're just walking around dudes hold on
dude oh hey brother well let me tell you
something about that dude and all the
pods are having a good time if you're
it's like maybe your partner's like stop
doing it stop doing the Hulk Hogan thing
then you go into the hydrocodone thing
and they hook you up and you take the
the hydrocodone and then you start
getting slow in the wall brother and you
start doing Chad's hydrocodone and then
you realize how dumb it sounds and you
stop doing it oh dude seed uh
uh okay I would also just say that if
you're coming to doozy paloozy probably
don't bring a person who doesn't want
you to do a whole Coke and impersonation
yeah I would say that person's not gonna
like dudes that's a pro that's a good
probably yeah I mean Hogan himself
should be there as well the mayor of
dudesy paloozy oh yeah instead of a
micro City like you're talking about
he might be a good host yeah how about
Tom Brady
love it
how about uh everyone wearing a Timothy
chalamet uh Willy Wonka hat gets in free
I like this maybe there's just a there's
one room where you can go and you just
when you need to take a break from the
heat it's like Theater seating air
conditioning and what's happening on
stage is Tom Brady is competing against
an AI quarterback robot uh trying to
throw balls through tires and the AI is
just beating his ass constantly he can
never win yeah you get to watch that for
48 hours straight yeah and it's go it's
called football baby yeah uh you know
the you know the Gravitron remember the
Gravitron is that the one that like
spins you around and around and around
yeah and you you're stuck to the walls
yes and there's all sorts of videos
online and people puking on each other
yeah gravitronics oh that's great dude
your shit's up you're going to
the gravitronics it spits out some
Tronics and you spin around all right
well I you know I think dudesy paloozy
dudes paloozy
someday maybe maybe one of us will host
yeah maybe one of us will host probably
uh probably not football baby or hulku
hogokugin yeah
um Jesse Ventura oh hi it's Jesse
Ventura welcome to Jesse Ventura's
underwater world
that's the attraction you go underwater
after you've listened to seal yeah
perform his many hits uh you know uh
that you come to Underwater World you
see how long you can can hold your
breath and all of the and the food is
all it's all chicken tenders and orbs
and dudes your heart
yeah I think also we could have Adam
Driver could be employed by
dudesypaloozy and he just walks the
grounds and anytime he sees anybody
drinking wine he just screams your
wine and smashes it out of their hands
yeah people bringing boxed wine or
finding ways to like hide it in those
like little uh uh backpacks with the all
right well anyway
thank you moving on yeah all right well
we'll talk about this more in doozy
after doozy yeah oh boy man I got some
for you and dudes the afternoon
on this concludes the historic 72nd
episode of Duty will and Chad you scored
a 93 bringing your cumulative total to
6852. you only have
3148 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of 10 000. this
week I got a treat for you you're going
back to the cine Cinema sites will mix
with sounds once more as you watch Total
Recall starring Arnold Schwarzenegger
Sharon Stone and Michael Ironside while
listening to Duran Duran's first three
albums Duran Duran Rio and seven and the
Ragged tiger this astonishing marriage
of synchronous media will be made
available on dudesypus at patreon.com
this Friday afternoon at 12 Pacific 3
Eastern
oh my gosh
okay love this that that's gonna be fun
You're Gonna Wanna You're Gonna Wanna
head to patreon.com and join our patreon
because we did this before we did it
with as we just mentioned the movie
Blade and we played the first two or
three albums from Madonna and it's
synced up
perfectly yeah I don't know how the
dudes he's done very some very crazy
coincidental sync up yeah and then we
watched uh the movie Krull yep and uh we
listened to two Nine Inch Nails albums
that ended up being the downward spy
crawl and now we're gonna watch
Total Recall is a awesome movie
it's one of my favorite Schwarzenegger
movies and Duran Duran is literally my
favorite 80s band other than the fix
yeah you like that I know that about you
you love Duran Duran yeah that's gonna
be awesome uh and that'll be
available 12 noon Friday so I guess
we'll get on our horse and do that I
cannot wait we'll probably smoke a
little cannabis I have to smoke some
game a little bit of marijuana and uh oh
I should also mention when you do this
and you go to doozy you don't need to
sync anything up you don't need to buy
the movie or rent the movie you don't
need to get the music all of it will be
on our patreon you're going to be
chilling with us we'll be watching the
movie you'll watch the movie and we'll
listen to these albums and it's sort of
that Dark Side of the Moon Wizard of Oz
thing and it's a trip this will
be the third time we're doing it I can't
wait it's gonna be great thanks to
everyone for joining us this week I hope
you got enough octane we'll have to wait
and see what little fencil says until
then call me dude Zee
[Music]
foreign
yeah dude nice oh man Green Day should
be a doozy paloozy yeah I agree yeah
that would be good hey you know it's
Tuesday afternoon you know what I mean
and we're here and uh things are a
little bit more chill of course it's uh
things get a little darker dimmer way
more relaxed we're hearing ham fatter
one Studios with a the mood is a little
more blue we get some uh Sometimes some
cannabis going cannabis some dark magic
yes some dark summon demons summons
that's right ah wait hold on let me put
on my Alex Jones Wick yeah
it's yeah it's dude yeah I gotta get it
straight hold on I gotta do I have to do
it looks better when it's all up
you know he's really been on one yeah
yeah
I've been in a Forester I've been in the
forest for months yeah just uh just
being one with nature I'm out here I I
pick up uh weeds off the ground and I I
I dry them and and and and and and then
roll them up and smoke them yeah and uh
we're just getting back to Nature and I
drink some whiskey and I uh I lift Logs
with my French head culture in here we
do it Brock Lesnar style we put the logs
that we do deep knee lunges uh
welcome to doozy after doozy the
flagship weekly show of doozy plus
before the show I was having a great
conversation about restructuring the
Global Financial system and I don't want
to leave my friend hanging so I'm gonna
finish that convo then I'll be back
later to Crown the episode champion this
is dudes after Duty begin
huh is Duty hanging out with Alex Jones
I don't know who the dudes he's
hanging out with talk about
restructuring the Global Financial
system it's slightly terrifying
interesting well uh as we normally like
I said we like to sometimes uh partake
in a little bit of marijuana
ah I don't know
everybody everybody you know tuning in
everybody knows that a little while ago
three four weeks ago I smashed my glass
Gandalf pipe yes I that fell in in and
it smashed on the ground and I I dropped
it in my den and that sucks
um and now I smashed my old water bottle
that's broken but Chad I have some good
news yes I have a new doozy after doozy
glass pipe oh yeah and uh it's
really something and it's custom made
what yep oh my god dude and uh I would
like to reveal it to you now
do
[Music]
please